[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france a 24 esta mañana de miércoles
mitad de semana rosa pérez mateo
bienvenida gracias raúl buenos días
buenos días rosa vamos a comenzar
entonces recomendando un impactante
declaración que tuvo lugar ayer martes
en la cadena estadounidense de noticias
cnn cuando el periodista jake tupper
entrevistó al ex consejero de seguridad
nacional de donald trump john vuelto una
noticia que raramente ha pasado
desapercibida no sí señor y es bastante
una declaración muy abierta y bastante
impactante la verdad la cuestión es que
ambos a john bolton conversa como dices
con el periodista de jacques tupper en
el marco de las audiencias sobre el
asalto al capitolio que intenta
esclarecer un poco la responsabilidad
entre otras cosas del ex presidente
donald trump bien en todo caso lo que
bolton defiende como ex consejo el ex
consejero de seguridad de donald trump
que lo conoce un poco como piensa y como
reflexiona lo que dice es que no se
trató que sería un error pensar que se
trató de una golpe de estado premeditado
a la democracia sino que más bien el
estilo de donald trump y este asalto al
capitolio fue lo que dice haciendo una
metáfora con el lenguaje y la película
de star wars una conmoción en la fuerza
y veamos el argumento de autoridad que
utiliza para defender su posicionamiento
escuchemos
no es un ataque a nuestra democracia es
donald trump actuando en su propio
beneficio es algo que ocurrió una sola
vez en la vida
con todo el respeto no sé si estoy de
acuerdo con usted para ser justos no
tiene que ser brillante para intentar
dar un golpe de estado si hubiese han
pecado no estoy de acuerdo como alguien
que ayudó a planear golpes de estado
nano aquí ya sabes en otros lugares
requiere mucho trabajo y eso no es lo
que hizo trump sólo iba a ciegas de una
idea a otra en última instancia sin
pensó a los amotinados a ir al capitolio
esto no ayuda bueno ante esta
declaración rosa me río para pues no
llorar cómo reacciona la prensa de eeuu
el mismo lo dijo sabemos ha ayudado a
concretar golpes de estado claro por
supuesto una que eeuu en otros países
como si fuera algo normal claro sea
analicemos esta afirmación no el
defiende el periodista y le dice no hace
falta ser brillante para orquestar un
golpe de estado ante lo que él dice no
yo que lo sé yo que ha ayudado a
organizar golpes de estados no aquí no
en eeuu sino en otros lugares
requiere mucho trabajo claro
digamos que dando fuerza a su argumento
de que es un trabajo demasiado serio y
demasiado meticuloso para que lo llevara
a cabo donald trump se declara partícipe
de la organización de golpes de estado
eso en otros lugares del mundo bien
primer inciso cabe destacar que ayer
durante estas audiencias no sobre el
asalto al capitolio el comité hizo
referencia a un tuit de donald trump del
18 de diciembre de 2020 en el que
digamos hacía una llamada a sus
seguidores a congregarse el 6 de enero
de 2021 en washington no diciendo be
there will be wild no estén ahí será
salvaje lo que ya da digamos a conocer
una cierta preparación no de lo que
acabó sucediendo pero en todo caso el
periodista directa y perth digamos que
se recompone de este shock de esta
confesión que le acaba de hacer a bolton
no confesándole eso que ha participado
en organizar golpes de estado en otros
países del mundo e intentan sonsacarle
más informe más información escuchemos
[Música]
me gustaría seguir con lo que hablamos
sobre qué se necesita para dar un golpe
de estado que usted dijo que tenía
experiencia planeando golpes de estado
no voy a entrar en detalles pero pero
golpes de estado con éxito en escribir
sobre venezuela en el libro finalmente
no tuvo éxito no es que tuviéramos tanto
que ver con él pero vi lo que implicó
para una oposición intentar derrocar un
presidente elegido ilegalmente y
fracasaron la idea de que donald trump
fuera la mitad de competente que la
oposición venezolana es ridícula eso
haya foto siento que hay cosas que no me
está contando
estoy seguro que las hay no son tan
buenos pero tampoco organizando esos
golpes de estado evidentemente vemos que
si apoyo digamos lo que dijo un golpe de
estado en venezuela pues ahí todavía
está la cosa igual rosa entonces como
como lo señala el presentado hablar sea
euronews y destacar que eeuu continúa
reconociendo a juan guaidó como
presidente interino de venezuela bien
hasta cuándo va a durar este
reconocimiento no lo sabemos y además el
gobierno se reunió con el presidente
maduro entonces es un doble discurso
la unión europea ya dio marcha atrás
también hace tiempo en este
reconocimiento bien en todo caso como
decías la prensa finalmente no hemos
visto una gran shock un gran impacto por
estas palabras por este reconocimiento
abierto y explícito de como la
administración estadounidense ha
participado en organizar golpes de
estados fuera de sus fronteras en todo
caso nos quedamos con el titular de
daily beast que es una revista sobre
política y medios de comunicación que
dice john bolton casual y admite no
admite espontáneamente a la cnn que
planeó golpes de estado eso sí en el
extranjero y hay que reconocerle que ya
poca gente quedará tan espontánea en las
entrevistas no así es rosa pues como
dice el dicho popular se sin querer
queriendo no se le salió obviamente esa
afirmación tan grave como siempre
gracias rosa por toda la información
mañana con más pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado al día